this is a bit of a departure for us
here at the late-night show my next
guest is here to show you how to keep
safe in the streets and not be a victim
of crime
please welcome self defense expert Fred
Armisen
what's up I'm Fred from the Minneapolis
Police now I'm here to talk to you about
self-defense keeping safe on the city
streets you don't have to be a victim
okay quick show of hands right here in
the audience how many people here carry
more than a dollar in cash on them at
any time raise your hands
that's stupid never ever carry more than
one dollar in cash on you at any time
you're gonna go to the store your ladies
are gonna buy a magnum p.i poster or
whatever get rung up run to the ATM get
that cash out exactly and pay it and
you're all set okay I don't want you to
be a victim I'm gonna introduce to you
my assistant in my assailant this is
John now the first thing you'll notice
is he's not black a lot of people say to
me always a black guy black people do
crime I don't need any of that racism in
here
and besides if you look at the
statistics nine times out of ten your
attacker is gonna be one of those dirty
Latinos
[Music]
now here's what you do if someone's
gonna attack you on the street
use your body you don't need any weapons
some of that comes at you you can use
your fingers to blind him
[Applause]
you can configure his body in such a way
to get him away from you
for example arm up arm down arm up arm
down elbow in shoulder down head down
head back up mouth open mouth closed
shoulder out push away and he's on his
way you can clap your hand too
definitely a sanguine yet people you
people gotta stay aware I did an
experiment today I walked up to fire
escapes and I watched two different
women take showers they never knew I was
there that's not right be aware now John
and I we do this at high schools across
the country why do I do it I'll tell you
why a little while ago my daughter was
abducted she was taken from me okay
and when that happened I vowed I would
spend the rest of my weekend searching
for her
what do you do if someone has a gun what
do you do you fight here's what you do
he's got about a quarter of an inch he
can use to pull that trigger I always
carry a pen with me everywhere I go pull
the gun towards you put this gun right
here you can't pull the trigger if you
don't have a pen get one from the
assailant
[Applause]
thank you
something else I carry with me is a
flashlight y-you might an ATM you can
distract them turn on the flashlight
when all else fails you can always use
your cell phone pretend like you're
having a conversation and leave you
alone give me your money give me
[Applause]
that's gonna be it for us but before we
go I want all you people here to repeat
a mantra from me everywhere you go in
this dangerous city you guys ready after
me
I am a castle my hands are arrows of
flame you cannot enter the castle until
I have brought down the bridge that goes
over the moat then encircles the castle
until a team proper to do so exactly at
that hour
[Applause]
all right well thank you very much
that's it
[Applause]